hablemos sobre qué animal es Goofy
un perro o
qué es un perro yo también
reunimos a 7 fanáticos de Disney soy
fanático de Disney de Disney
de Disney
1 es el impostor si el grupo descubre
quién es el impostor se repartirán un
premio en efectivo
[Música]
si el impostor se queda ganará todo el
premio
quién es el impostor
cuál es tu época favorita de Disney
blazing hizo
la gente piensa en eso de acuerdo
supongo que lo hacen bien
un poco de la Edad de Plata y un poco de
recoger
todo
Robin Williams y si la película es esto
será
posible me gusta que hayáis disfrutado
persona la mía es la dama y el vagabundo
veía dos perros enamorarse que era como
interesante pero pensaba estoy incómoda
[Música]
llama al estaba un poco callado solo
estaba de acuerdo con la gente pero no
respondía a las preguntas
[Música]
cuando fui a ella estaba como tiene algo
tiene algo muy extraño
[Música]
tenemos un empate
el empate es entre Erik y haya
vamos a un desempate en el que cada uno
de ustedes nos dirá alguna anécdota de
Disney y el por qué mi anécdota es que
Disney no trata bien a sus empleados la
pandemia de Kobe fue el mayor ejemplo de
ello despidieron a todos sus empleados
sin paga me parece incorrecto apoyarlos
después de eso aunque estés apoyando los
creativos y a la gente que está detrás
de la magia que hay descontinuaron los
pases anuales
[Música]
me hubiera gustado tener otra
oportunidad tengo un tatuaje de Disney
creo que yo hubiera demostrado que soy
un fanático de Disney hablemos de qué
animal es Goofy es
un perro o una vaca
siempre diré que es un pero le gusta una
vaca es una de esas cosas que esperan
que olvidemos como niños y ahora no
podemos trabajar en Disney durante 3
años hasta el despido cuando la gente me
preguntaba si maxgood era un perro o que
intentaba decir como un perro porque eso
era lo que nos decían que dijéramos que
era un perro Vanessa ya había mencionado
que había trabajado en Disney es una
manera fácil y constante de aprender
datos y cosas de Disney Chester me veía
que estabas echando mucho de mí yo solo
quería trabajar en el lugar más el mundo
cuál es su canción favorita de Disney es
no hablaré de mi amor demis
creo que estoy
en realidad
esto y por eso sabe mucho del tema
ninguno de los dos porque soy de Chicago
y es muy caro
pero es comprensible de verdad
[Música]
[Risas]
dice que le gusta el Disney de los 90
los años 90 eran cuando Disney estaba en
su máximo esplendor así que sería lo más
fácil de conocer
[Música]
bote por la vender porque su lenguaje
corporal decía algo así como que no
quiero estar aquí
tenemos un empate
el empate entre Jamal y Lavender
vamos a hacer un desempate en el que
cada uno de ustedes nos dirá cuál es su
película favorita de Disney y por qué
pregunta más difícil pero me gusta la
dama y el vagabundo más que nada me
encantan los dibujos animados y la
música una de mis cantantes favoritas y
son la canción que es un bebé la luz la
luz y he llamado a todas mis novias
reina por esa película
[Música]
gracias chicos adiós pensé que estaba
bien pero sé que muchos dicen que frozen
en sus películas favoritas y qué es lo
que es
por favor levanten la mano si quieren
continuar el juego en 3 2 1
creo que todos somos fanáticos podemos
terminar el coito esto será la ronda de
experiencias mágicas
cada uno de ustedes tendrá la
oportunidad de contar a los demás cuál
fue su experiencia más mágica con Disney
crecí siendo pobre y la única vez que
pude ir a Disney fue con mi abuelo rico
adoptada y no tenía relación con nadie
más que con mi abuelo fue genial
integrarme con la familia y también
construir una relación con mi abuelo que
acaba de morir el año pasado estar sin
él ha sido difícil pero lo siento
conmigo para mira Disney es mágico
cuando empecé a conducir casi me dan una
multa por velocidad me detuvo la policía
me asusté y estaba tan nerviosa que
cuando me pidió la licencia fui a tomar
mi cartera y le entregué otra tenía mi
licencia de Autopía cartera me confundí
y se la entregué en la miro y me dejó ir
llegue a casa y le dije vaya me libéré
de una multa me libéré de una multa me
salvo dice como ya trabajé en Disney
pero no tenía un papel en específico
estaba en el departamento de
entretenimiento y pasaban mucho tiempo
vestida como los personajes había
momentos en los que lloraba porque veía
todas esas familias juntas era muy
bonito tengo como recuerdos fotográficos
de eso y estoy muy agradecida también
tengo muchos recuerdos mágicos de Disney
algunos propios y otros de mi hijo lo
llevaba Disney todo el tiempo pude
pagarnos el pase anual hubo una vez que
le compré un globo el globo se rompió y
él se puso muy triste dije que le
compraría otros son un poco caros pero
no importa pregunté puedo comprar otro
este se rompió y ellos dijeron claro y
le dieron uno gratis estaba como que no
fue hasta que vi fuegos artificiales
musicalizados por primera vez que creo
que era believe o eso creo fue uno de
los primeros viajes que hice con mis
amigos y fue la primera vez que fui sin
mi familia pienso en ello todo el tiempo
mis 4 mejores amigos de la infancia y yo
y recuerdo estar allí sentirme sumamente
feliz
[Música]
muy mal quieras lo siento
vote por Kira pensé que tal vez es solo
una madre de Disney y no una fanática de
Disney
[Música]
yo
está bien por favor si desean continuar
en el juego levanten la mano en 3 2 1
tengo una sospecha lo siento
yo seguía teniendo la sospecha de que
era Vanesa el hecho de que fuera un
miembro del elenco hace muy fácil de que
obtengas es información porque está
incluida en el entrenamiento a muchas
personas no les gusta su lugar de
trabajo quién sabe
si es una de ustedes tendremos problemas
si la luz se pone en verde significa que
han expulsado al impostor y todos ganan
si la luz se pone roja significa que el
impostor sigue en la caja y ustedes
pierden
[Aplausos]
eres tú no
ahora es personal venía la sospecha el
impostor por favor dar un paso adelante
y revelar su identidad en tres dos uno
lo siento mucho
soy una odiadora de Disney pero como soy
la impostora puede que me lo haya creído
el personaje que era es una de mis
amigas que si es una fanática favor a mí
no me gusta Disney como compañía y me
gusta defender lo que creo cuando tienes
tanta influencia sobre los niños me
gustaría que priorizará hacer la vida de
los niños mucho más feliz que el dinero
que hay detrás se merece un Óscar
ella hizo todo el trabajo creo que se
ganó ese dinero me gustaría ir a Disney
con todos ustedes
[Risas]